of the morning session is by oren
mangubi
uh the talk is based on joint work with
the nishid vaishnay oren has done
a lot of interesting work on mcmc
methods
metropolized lounge event hamiltonian
monte carlo and also on
random walks
and
this talk is going to be about using
random walks to obtain faster algorithms
for
polytope rounding and volume computation
so oren please go ahead
okay uh so thank you
so today i'll be talking about
faster polytope rounding sampling and
volume computation
via sublinear ball walk
so this talk is based on a paper in
fox 2019 which is a joint work with
nish
so i'll start off by talking about the
problem setting
and motivation
and then i'll talk about some previous
approaches to this problem
then i'll talk about our algorithm
and
finally i'll talk about how
we bound the running time of our
algorithm
uh okay so we consider the problem where
we're given a polytope
in
r to the n which is defined by a set of
m inequalities
and this polytope so we assume that this
polytope contains a ball of some radius
lowercase r and it's also contained in a
ball of some
larger radius uppercase r
and so the goal
is to find a linear transformation for
the polytope which brings it into
isotropic position
so in other words uh we want to find a
linear trump transformation which makes
the covariance matrix of
the polytope to be roughly equal to the
identity
covariance matrix up to some constant
factor
so this problem is also
sometimes called rounding the problem of
rounding the polytope
okay so why do we care about this
problem
of rounding the polytope
uh so one reason is
that once we put the polytope into
isotropic position so once we find a
linear transformation which makes uh the
polygons have roughly identity
covariance matrix then it actually
becomes much easier to generate samples
from the unit form distribution on the
polytope uh so for example if we want to
generate many samples from the polytope
uh maybe
in some bayesian statistics application
where we want to
compute some integral or some statistic
so then
this can oftentimes be
done much faster
by first finding a linear transformation
which brings the polytope into isotropic
position and then
generating
many samples
by running a random walk on the polytope
so another reason
we care about this problem of rounding
proli cope is that it also makes it much
easier to compute the volume of the
polytope uh so specifically in the
setting where the number
of inequalities m defining the polytope
is greater than or equal to
uh
the cube of the dimension uh so the
previous uh bottleneck before this work
in computing
uh the volume of the polytope uh is
actually this pre-processing step where
one rounds uh the polytope and brings it
into isotropic positions so if you can
improve uh the
number of operations the number of
arithmetic operations that it takes to
round the
top then you also improve the number of
arithmetic operations
that it takes to compute the volume of
the polytope
okay so there's actually a long line of
work on
the problem of computing the volume of a
polytope so generally what one does to
compute the polytope volume is that one
first generates samples from the uniform
distribution on the polytope and this
then allows one to compute
the volume of the polytope in polynomial
time
so typically these samples are generated
by running a markov chain on the
interior of the polytope or on a
sequence of polytubes where the last
polytope in the sequence is the polytope
k whose volume we want to compute
okay so in
the first
column in this table we have various
markup chains which appear in
recent uh prior works and some of these
markov chains imply
the best uh previous bounce uh before i
work for computing a polytope volume in
different regimes
so that's the first column and in the
second column of this table we also have
the number of arithmetic operations that
these markov chains require in order to
compute the volume
of the polytope
so the number of arithmetic operations
depends on two things so first of all it
depends on the number of markov chain
steps that the markov chain requires to
compute the volume of
a polytope so that's this kind of middle
column here right after the equal sign
and
it also depends on the number of
arithmetic operations that we require to
implement each individual step
of
the
relevant markov chain
so most password has focused on reducing
the number of markov chain steps
required to compute the polytone volume
but in this talk we're instead going to
consider
the problem of reducing the number of
arithmetic operations that are required
to
implement each individual step of the
markov chains
so in other words
so in this talk we're going to try to
we're going to reduce the number of
operations per step
of the markov chain
and specifically we would like to reduce
uh the number of operations per step for
the ball lock markov chain uh so that it
is sublinear in the input size of the
problem and in this case
so the input size of the problem is the
number of inequalities m times the
dimension n
so all previous markov chains which can
be used to sample from a polytope uh
require a number of
arithmetic operations which is at least
linear in m times n
you compute each step
of the markov chain
so we would like to reduce this number
of arithmetic operations so that it is
instead sublinear in n times n and we're
going to do this for the ball walk
markov chain
okay so now i'll
now talk a bit about our results uh so
we know so we show that when uh sampling
from a polytope in isotropic position we
can implement the ball lock markov chain
in roughly m operations per markov chain
step on average
uh so this is sublinear in the input
size m times n
and we then show that this result
implies a cost of roughly m times n to
the fourth times psi squared arithmetic
operations to round the polytope
so in other words to bring the polytope
into isotropic position and it also
implies the same number of arithmetic
operations to compute the polytope
volume so what is this constant size
squared so
psi is a bound on
the kls constant
so when our original result was
published
the best current bound was
psi equals n to the 1 4
so that's how
our original result was stated
however
since then the best bound on the kls
constant has been improved to psi equals
d to the delta for any delta greater
than zero
so with some
small modifications to our proof this
then implies uh improved bounds for our
algorithm as well this improved
kls constant
okay so our algorithm improves on the
previous best bound for rounding a
polytope by a factor of n times
this kls constant psi to the minus 2
so we get this improvement in the regime
where the number of inequalities m is
greater than or equal to the dimension n
cubed
and since the rounding pre-passing
pre-processing step is currently the
bottleneck for volume computation in
this regime uh we also get an
improvement of end time
side to the minus 2 for the number of
arithmetic operations it takes to
compute the volume
of the polytope
okay so here we have a more formal
statement of our result
so our algorithm is based on the ball
walk mark off chain uh so what's the
ball walk monkey chain so the ball walk
is a markov chain on the interior
of a polytope or more generally the
interior of a convex body
so at each point uh in this ball lock
markov chain
to compute the next point in a markov
chain the ball lock
algorithm first proposes a step which is
uniformly distributed on a ball of
radius 1 over root n centered at
the current markov chain point
so if this proposed step satisfies all m
inequalities which define the polytope
then the ball walk moves uh to the uh
proposed step and if it not then it
proposes a
different random step it stands where it
is and it proposes a new uh random step
uh so this means that in order to
compute each step of the balwak markov
chain uh we have to check
uh all m
inequalities which define the polytope
uh so the question we have is this
so how can we avoid computing all m
inequalities
at each step
of the ball walk markov chain
so to solve this problem
we introduce a sublinear implementation
of the ballot markov chain so the way
this implementation
works is as follows
so first of all at this initial point x1
of the balwa markov chain we compute the
distance to each face
of
the polytope
uh so in other words uh we want to
compute uh we compute the distance to
each hyperplane uh which defines a face
of a polytope
uh so we compute so we have this
distance delta i
uh that we compute to each
of these hyperplanes
h i defining the face of the polytope
and we then wait roughly delta i times n
ball walk steps before checking the
distance to the hyperplane h i again
so the main idea is this so at each step
of the ball walk markov chain we only
compute a very small subset of the
distances to each of these hyperplanes
because
we're weighting
delta i times
10 steps before computing
this distance again
so this allows us to implement each step
of the ball walk mock off chain in a
much smaller number of arithmetic
operations than if we were then if we
had to compute uh
the
check every inequality at each step
okay so so now we have we need to answer
two questions
so the first question
is
why does this implementation of the ball
walk actually work
so in other words why does the ball lock
not leave the polytope since we're only
checking a small subset of the
inequalities at each step
so to prove that this implementation of
the ball walk doesn't fail with high
probability we can see that each
proposed step of the ball walk markov
chain is uniformly distributed on a ball
of radius 1 over square root of n
so this implies that at each step the
ball walk travels at most a distance of
roughly one over n in the direction of
any given hyper plane which defines a
face of the polytope
so this is with high probability
um so in other words
with very high probability if we wait
roughly delta i times n
ball lock steps uh where delta i is the
distance we computed to each hyperplane
h i uh so if you wait uh that many steps
before recomputing the distance to that
hyperplane then our ball walk will not
leave the polytope uh for a very long
time uh with high probability
uh so more
specifically if we want our ball walk to
not fail for a very large number of
steps uh t
uppercase t then we need to wait a long
time
when we need to wait a time of roughly
delta i times n
uh log to the minus one of t
before
uh recomputing
uh this
uh
the distance to this hyperplane
okay so this shows that our algorithm
does not fail with high probability and
it also shows that with high probability
our algorithm will follow the exact same
steps as the original ball walk markov
chain uh for this very long time t
okay so so far we've shown that our
algorithm
succeeds
in
implementing the ball lock but we still
need to show that it implements the ball
walk faster
than the naive implementation
so we want to show that our algorithm
implements uh more specifically we want
to show that our algorithm implements
the balwak fact
by a factor of n
faster and arithmetic operations uh
faster than the naive implementation
so to do that we want to
bound the expected waiting time
which is this distance delta i we
computed to each
hyper plane h i times n so that's the
expected waiting time and to show that
we need to show that on average this
quantity is greater than or equal to
roughly n and this will if we can show
that then this will lead to a factor of
n
improvement in the running time of the
ball walk
okay so we only
know
how to bound uh the expected waiting
time when uh the polytope
is in isotropic position
uh so in order to allow us to round uh
the polytope by sampling only from uh
isotropic polytopes so
isotropic convex bodies more
specifically isotropic convex bodies
which are very close uh in some sense uh
to being polytopes so their intersection
of polytopes with a ball
so we consider a sequence of roughly n
of these uh near nearly polytope convex
bodies
so each convex body in the sequence can
be transformed into isotropic position
by computing roughly n samples from the
previous convex body in the sequence
so this construction allows us to round
the polytope by sampling only from
isotropic uh convex bondings uh so this
is the same uh so the same construction
also allows us to initialize our markov
chain at a roughly
a uniform random point inside each of
these
convex bodies
okay so how do we bound the total
running time
time of the algorithm of our algorithm
so there are roughly n convex bodies
inside
this sequence and we generate n
independent samples from each of these
convex bodies so that's n squared
independent samples in
total that we need to generate
throughout this rounding procedure
so
we also show that
the expected cost of each step of the
ball walk is roughly equal to the number
m of faces of the polytope
so we'll also show that
and uh we also know that uh the ball
walk uh markov chain mixes in uh another
steps which is roughly n squared times
the kls constant size squared
on an isotropic convex body uh so this
result is due
uh to
the recent work uh by chen and
previously
by leanne vappar and other authors so
the
um
so every time this bound on the
kls constant improved this also implies
an improved bound
on
the running time of the ball walk
the mixing time of the ball walk
so putting these uh basically these
three uh facts together so the fact that
we need n squared
samples and
that each step of the ball walk
so we're going to show that it takes
roughly
m arithmetic operations to compute and
finally that the balwak mixes in n
squared times
psi squared steps uh putting these three
facts together uh we get that our
algorithm uh takes roughly m times n to
the fourth psi squared of arithmetic
operations uh to in order to bring the
polytope into isotropic position
okay so we still need to do
one more thing
so in order to bound the expected cost
of each ballbox death and it to show
that it only requires m operations uh to
compute we need to bound the expected
waiting time uh before
we recomp we have to recompute each um
the distance to each uh
hyperplane that defines a polytope
so this distance delta i
and
so the expected waiting time is then
going to be
the
expectation of delta i times n
so this is the expected waiting time
until we compute
the distance
to our hyperplane again
but we still need to bound the
expectation of this distance delta i
okay so how do we do that uh so to do
that we first so how do we bound the
expectation of uh this distance uh delta
i to any uh given hyperplane defining
the polytope
uh so to do that we're going to show
an
anti-concentration lemma
for polytopes
in isotropic position
uh so so what does this lemma say so
basically uh what
our lama says is that if we have a point
x that is uniformly distributed inside
the polytope so you sample this point x
from the uniform distribution on the
polytope
and if the polytope is in isotropic
position
then if we look at the distance between
this point x and any face of the
polytope
or more
specifically any hyperplane defining
h i defining phase of the polytope
then the probability that this distance
is less than or equal to uh some uh
number epsilon uh is bounded by roughly
epsilon
okay so what does this mean so in other
words uh what this lemma is saying is
that if we look at this red
strip here so this red region
consisting of all the points that are a
distance at most
some number epsilon
from any given face of the polytope then
the volume of this red region is a
fraction of at most epsilon of the total
volume of the polytope
so
basically this is an anti-concentration
lemma it says that the volume of the
polytope does not concentrate too much
near any of the faces of the polytope
okay so why do we care about this limits
how does this lemma help us
so since our construction allows us to
start the ball walk at a roughly uniform
random point
so in other words from
a warm start
and our polytope is in roughly isotropic
position at each point in this
construction
uh then if we apply this
anti-concentration lemma uh it implies
that the expected distance to each face
of the polytope at every step of the
ball walk is roughly equal to something
on the order of one
so in other words this implies that
the expected
waiting time until we
compute each
have to compute each hyperplane again
is equal to
the expectation of delta i times n
and since the expectation of delta is
roughly 1 then this means that we have
to write weight roughly n ball lock
steps before
uh computing any uh given hyperplane
again so
again this is an average case bound
um
okay so basically uh we've shown that on
average we only need to compute the
distance to each hyperplane of the
polytope once every n steps of a ball
walk
so in other words this means that we get
an improvement of roughly a factor of n
on the number of arithmetic operations
needed
to implement each ball walk step
okay so we still uh of course need to
show
that this anti-concentration lemma holds
so why does it hold
so roughly since uh the polytope is in
isotropic position the uniform
distribution on the polytope is a log
and the uniform distribution on the
polytope is a low concave distribution
um and it also has a covariance matrix
that is roughly equal
to the
identity covariance matrix
right so we have
so the reason that uh this law concave
distribution which is the uniform
distribution on the polytope has roughly
identity covariance matrix is because uh
we've brought the polytope uh into
isotropic position
uh so we're interested in uh the
distance from any uh point x which is
sampled at random from the uniform
distribution on the polytope uh the
distance between this point x and any uh
hyperplane
uh so this hybrid plane could be a face
of the polytope so this is what we care
about in in the application to our
algorithm uh but more generally for the
purpose of this lemma it could actually
just be
we could be looking at the distance
between x and any
fixed hyperplane
so it turns out that
whenever we project
this
a lock concave distribution onto a lower
dimensional subspace the marginal
distribution that we get on this
subspace
after projecting
is also always a long concave
distribution
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take
the uniform distribution on the polytope
and we're going to project this
distribution
onto the line orthogonal
to the given
hyperplane
and so the marginal distribution on this
orthogonal line will also be have to be
a log concave distribution
and
and
since the original
uniform distribution on the polytope had
covariance matrix roughly equal to the
identity covariance matrix this means
that the marginal distribution on
of on the line orthogonal uh to
this hyperplane will have variance uh
roughly one so now we basically have a
one dimensional log concave distribution
uh which has variance one and this
distribution tells us uh the distance
between uh the point x and uh the given
uh hyperplane
so now we can basically use this fact to
show that with uh probability at least
one minus epsilon the distance from x to
the hyperplane is
um
more than
epsilon
okay so uh since
uh the time uh that uh the work in this
uh talk was published there has been um
some uh
other improvements relating uh to
sampling from polytopes and more
generally from
convex bodies so uh one improvement uh
which i already mentioned was that the
best bound for the kls constant psi has
been improved from d to the one fourth
to d to the delta for any uh delta
greater than zero
and there have also been improved other
improvements to the rounding for
procedures for the ball walk which
allows one to round a convex body
in
roughly n cubed times psi squared calls
to a membership oracle
so in particular if one combines this
new uh rounding procedure uh with our
sublinear
ball walk algorithms the one mentioned
in this talk then this allows one to
round the polytope in
uh roughly m times n to the 3.5
times
psi
squared arithmetic operations
and so another
uh
recent result in the same paper
is that using a different algorithm with
a fast matrix multiplication one can
actually improve this bound further
to m times n to the 3.24 psi squared
arithmetic operations
okay so on so far
uh we've shown how to improve the per
step complexity of the ball walk from m
times n to m
in
the context of polytope rounding and
volume computation
and this improves on the previous bounds
for the polytope for both polytope
rounding and volume computation by a
factor of roughly n times psi to the
minus 2
to n times n to the 4
side squared arithmetic operations
so now i'll talk a bit about future
directions so basically so far we've
shown how to improve the per step
complexity of the ball lock from m times
n
to just
m arithmetic operations
uh so an improvement
so in other words this was an
improvement by a factor of n in the
context of polytope rounding and volume
complication so uh the first question uh
that we have
uh is
uh can we get the same factor of an
improvement to the per step complexity
of the ball walk when the polytope is in
well-rounded but not in isotropic
positions so why do we care about this
question so one reason is because so due
to recent improvements in a rounding
procedure
um so you can get uh
you can round the pie to open a fewer
number of membership oracle calls but
at each step in the rounding procedure
uh the polytope uh so rather than
bringing the polytope into isotropic
position you instead only bring it into
at most of these iterations into
well-rounded position but not into
isotropic position
um
so
if we can so this means that if we can
um
improve
uh if we can show the same factor of an
improvement to the per step complexity
of the bulwark
that we already showed for
polytopes in isotropic position
and if we so if we can extend this
improvement uh to
any polytope in well-rounded position uh
then this would improve uh
the
uh most recent
subsequent bounce
by a factor of rosh lee m to the 0.24
so our
second question
is can we make further improvements to
the per step complexity of the boac
beyond this factor of n
improvement
that we've already made so the
conjecture that we have is that the per
step complexity of the ballok is
actually logarithmic in m where m is the
number of uh inequalities defining uh
the polytope
and finally our last question uh is can
we improve the per step complexity of
other polytope
sampling algorithms which may mix in
fewer
steps in many settings so in particular
reminding hmc hit and run markov chain
or the
dai can walk
let's take let's thank oren
[Applause]
are there any questions we have uh
five minutes we can take uh
a few questions if uh
so let me maybe start with the question
so okay can you
explain
a little bit uh about
what is the main technical challenge
if you want to
uh sample from non-isotropic position
like what breaks in in your current
techniques or what is missing in the
current techniques
okay so if you want if you're
considering the ball lock on a polytope
but the polytope is not in isotropic
position
yes yes that's
right so
okay so how do we prove uh this
anti-concentration lemma so basically uh
what we do so first
so if the polytope is in
isotropic position this means
that
the covariance matrix of the uniform
distribution on the polytope is roughly
equal to the identity covariance matrix
and then if we
uh
project
so we want to know uh what's the
distribution of
the distance between this uniform random
point x inside the polytope
and uh any hyperplane in the space
so it can be either
a face of the polytope or or any other
hyperplane
uh so if the unif if the uniform
distribution on the polytope has
identity covariance matrix and then we
look at the marginal
distribution
uh of this uh uniform distribution on
the poly dope on this
dotted line
so this dotted line is the line
orthogonal
to
this hyperplane hi
so this will imply that
the
variance of of this marginal
distribution is one
and since the variance is one this
basically
says that
the
um the probability that uh the point x
is within epsilon uh a distance epsilon
of this hyperplane uh so this
probability cannot be
um
greater than uh epsilon and the reason
is because
uh this distribution is both has
variance one and
um is a log concave uh distribution
so if the polytope were not in isotropic
uh position then we wouldn't know uh
that
we wouldn't have uh be guaranteed that
this
uh the variance of this marginal uh
distribution
on the line orthogonal to the to the
hyperplane
uh
we wouldn't have a guarantee that this
is this variance is uh roughly one
i see
thank you
so uh there's another question from the
audience just one second
let's talk
wondering uh for the last slide the
second conjecture can you explain the
intuition why it's a log m
the conjecture
right so why
why is it um
log of m
uh so basically
well so first of all we're not
i'm not sure if this conjecture
uh is uh true
um
but the main reason is that uh
right it can't really be more more than
log of n
what is the reason for that
so can i answer
maybe an answer is that you don't expect
a uniform random point to be close to
too many hyperplanes
i mean the ones that are close is what
you need to check
probably it's true that
if you go
to the intersection of log m hyperplanes
that's a very small space
[Music]
right
was there anything else you want to add
or
yeah so that was basically
uh the reason
uh but i mean we don't have
uh i mean we don't have any reason
to believe that it's it's uh true
so
at this point it's more based on
intuition
rather than having proof
sounds good
okay so let's uh thank corian again
at this point we have the lunch break
which is on your own and we will be back
here
at 2pm for two more talks which will